This is our timeline of the history of Genetics.
So far, we have covered the important milestones
up to this point.
Yes, we have taken a look at the work of Gregor
Mendel, followed by the work of Sutton and
Boveri.
This was the Chromosomal Theory of Inheritance.
Later, it was Thomas Hunt Morgan who put forth
his work on the common fruit fly and achieved
another milestone.
Now comes the next one!
After Morgan gave an experimental evidence
of the fact that genes for the traits are
present on the chromosomes, the scientific
world then got together to find out what exactly
makes up these genes and chromosomes.
In other words, the chemical nature of this
genetic material is what everyone was curious
to know about!
In the same era, a British bacteriologist
was busy handling his pneumococcal strains.
They are nothing but the bacteria named Streptococcus
pneumoniae, which are the causative agents
of pneumococcal infections.
Fredrick Griffith found that there is some
factor that helps TRANSFORM one bacterial
type into the other.
Let us have a look at his remarkable experiment!
To begin with, we need to get introduced to
the two types of pneumococcal strains.
This one is a smooth strain, denoted as the “S” strain.
And this one is a rough strain, denoted as the “R” strain.
Why are they named so?
Well, this smooth strain as we can see, has
a smooth outer surface.
It’s the capsule around the cell wall which
protects it from various threats.
The presence of this capsule makes the strain
virulent, or strongly infectious to be precise!
The absence of such a smooth coat makes this
strain avirulent, or non-infectious to be
precise!
Why is the R strain avirulent you may ask...
It’s the absence of the capsule which makes
it susceptible to the immune cells of the
host’s body!
Now getting back to Griffith’s work, let
us see what experiment he exactly performed…
He first injected a mouse with the “S”
strain, which is the smooth strain of pneumococci.
As expected, the mouse died.
Similarly, on injecting another mouse with
a rough strain, the mouse survived.
This was pretty much anticipated by him because
the “Rough” strain is usually the avirulent
one.
What was done next?
Now the third mouse was injected with the
“S” strain, but AFTER the bacteria were
heat killed.
That means he heated the ‘S’ strain to
extreme temperatures, which killed the virulent
strain and made it ineffective.
So the injected mouse survived!
Now comes the last part!
This time Griffith injected a mouse with a
mixture of both, rough strain and heat killed
smooth strain.
Yes, a mixture of the rough strain and the
HEAT KILLED smooth strain.
What do you think would have happened?
Most of us would expect the mouse to survive
because both are individually ineffective
or avirulent.
However, to his astonishment, the mouse did
not survive!
How did this happen?
And what do you think Griffith concluded?
With this, he concluded that there was SOMETHING
from the “S” strain that was PASSED ON
to the “R” strain, resulting it to turn “Virulent”.
Also, do you know what he recovered from the
body of the mouse?
He recovered live “S” strain.
Surprising isn’t it?
This further confirmed that the “R” strain
was transformed into the virulent “S”
strain.
He named the ”transforming factor” as
the “TRANSFORMATION PRINCIPLE”.
He did not really know what exactly this was,
and hence named it just the “transformation
principle”.
But he predicted that this could be the genetic material.
Was this really the genetic material?
Or was it something else?
Let us find that out in the next part!
Imagine we are given a bag full of flowers.
And we are told that there is one flower which
has the “Midas effect”.
Anything that the flower touches, gets transformed into
gold!
But how will we find out which flower is the special one?
All the flowers look more or less the same!
Well, the only thing we can do is make all
the flowers touch some object.
Isn’t that right?
So examining every individual flower is the
only option we have!
The story was similar in the case of
“TRANSFORMATION
PRINCIPLE”.
After Griffith concluded his experiment on
the bacteria named Streptococcus pneumoniae,
the science world was now curious to know
more about the transformation principle.
Finding the answers was not a piece of cake though!
It was almost two decades later that three
scientists figured out what this transformation
principle was!
They tried finding out its chemical nature
by testing every single component of the virulent
bacterial strain.
Let us move a step ahead in the timeline and
understand the interesting experiment performed
by Avery, MacLeod and McCarty around the year 1944.
The three scientists were quite fascinated
with Griffith’s work.
Just like others, even they were curious to
know what the transformation principle was!
So they thought of continuing the same experiment
with better research!
Griffith concluded his experiment by inferring
that there is some “factor” that is passed
from the heat killed virulent strain to the
rough strain which is avirulent.
This factor transforms the avirulent strain
to the virulent type.
So the three scientists thought of planning
the experiment by targeting the heat killed
smooth strain.
Just like our bag filled with flowers, the
smooth strain cells had various chemical components
in them.
And just like how we had to examine the touch
of individual flowers, the scientists mixed
every single chemical component individually
with the rough strain.
So let’s say this smooth strain cell had
these 4 components A, B, C and D in it.
They mixed the component “A” with the
rough strain and injected it in a live mouse.
Similarly, they mixed all the other components
individually with the rough strains and injected
the mixtures in different mice.
What they found at the end was, only one of
those components among all, was effective
in transforming the rough strain.
It was the case in which the mouse died.
The conclusion was that component “D”
transformed the “R” strain!
They isolated this component from the heat
killed strain and tested it further.
On chemical analysis they could figure out
that the molecules had a chemical composition
similar to that of DNA.
Deoxyribonucleic Acid, abbreviated as DNA,
was known to people by this time.
But it was not given much importance.
Nobody assumed that it could be such a vital
part of the cell.
In fact, people thought that “PROTEINS”
made up the cells.
And it was also believed that proteins make
up the GENETIC material.
So this experiment was a huge breakthrough
in genetics!
Many tests were carried out to investigate
this further and the chemical composition
of this Transformation principle was found.
It had components in the ratio that were found
in the DNA molecules.
So to FURTHER understand its nature, this
component was tested using chemicals that
break down the constituents.
For example, certain enzymes like protease
degrade proteins.
Use of such chemicals help us identify the
constituents in a given sample as they will
degrade specific molecules only.
So in this case, the chemicals used to degrade
DNA were used along with others and it was
found that the chemicals successfully broke
down the molecules.
It implied that the molecules were that of DNA.
This chemical analysis helped in understanding
that the “Transformation Principle” was
nothing else but DNA.
But this wasn’t easily accepted as a fact!
A few years later, another experiment helped
confirm the fact that it is indeed the DNA
which is the transformation principle
Let us find out more about the experiment
in the next part!
Until then, do not forget to subscribe to
our channel in order to get notified about
our latest uploads!